KENNETH LOO: The very
first time I did it
I remember all I felt was panic.
But once I got over that
panic, stressful feeling,
it began to feel natural.
I guess it's the feeling
you'd get if you were a bird.
I actually feel like
I'm the one in the air.
MANUEL ALEGRIA: You're
completely immersed.
It's a great feeling.
For us, it's a way to relax.
MATT RANDAZZO: Like I
describe to most anyone
I talk to about
flying, I say it's
like driving a hummingbird.
I can fly around
through the trees.
It's literally a
technologically-enabled,
out-of-body experience.
KENNETH LOO: FPV stands
for First Person View.
It's flying through the
perspective of a camera mounted
on the frame of the multirotor.
MANUEL ALEGRIA: It's
real, real all out racing.
It's about pushing the limits.
We want to keep going and
get faster and better.
MATT RANDAZZO: And there's
no money, obviously,
in these races.
But it's bragging rights when
someone can come in first
or come in at all.
MANUEL ALEGRIA: It can be
pretty dangerous if you
don't know what you're doing.
It's all out, nonstop.
They'll chop you up if you
get hit, crash into the trees.
A few of them have
burned up on me.
KENNETH LOO: I think
it's a good day if I
don't break any propellers.
MANUEL ALEGRIA: Oh!
Bring it in.
Bring it back!
KENNETH LOO: And I only have
a good day if I'm not racing.
MANUEL ALEGRIA: Out
on the field there's
a lot of joking, a lot of
anger, a lot of yelling.
It's a ton of fun.
KENNETH LOO: To me it's
definitely a passion.
Some people say, is
that really a sport?
But half the challenge
of flying a multirotor
is building it efficiently.
There's just as
much time invested
into building and
tuning the quads,
just like there is into building
and tuning a NASCAR vehicle.
And right now I tend to do
all of that stuff in my garage
and then go race.
But there are organizations
now, like Game of Drones,
Aerial Sports League.
And they're truly
making it competitive.
MANUEL ALEGRIA:
Am I in the lead?
Who's in the lead?
It seems like a
community is developing.
It's a small community, but it's
getting bigger and bigger now.
KENNETH LOO: The
community of people,
they're just so friendly and
willing to share information
on how to make your plane,
your helicopter fly more
efficiently, fly
faster, fly longer,
whatever you want it to do.
MATT RANDAZZO: We
are experiencing
a massive engineering
push on all these.
In the last year,
these things have
evolved so much that the
quad that you got a year ago
is outdated.
KENNETH LOO: Right now we're
at a very exciting moment
in this hobby because these
FPV racing leagues are just
starting to form.
So there are all of these
areas for the hobby and both
the sport to develop.
So it's really exciting and
you can sense that anybody
can really make a difference.
MATT RANDAZZO: I think
this is going to explode.
I think this is going to be kind
of similar to-- I hate to say
this-- like a NASCAR event.
There's going to be
professional racing.
I think this is going
to get really big.
KENNETH LOO: I think it would be
awesome if the hobby developed
into a real sport,
where pilots became
as well known as quarterbacks.
MANUEL ALEGRIA: I can't stop.
It's like an addiction.
I don't know.
It's really fun.
Woo!
I can't believe I-- oh, hoo hoo!
NARRATOR: All Points
Project is a part
of Seeker Stories,
a channel that
features short documentaries
from around the globe.
Please check out our
video about the plight
to save New Mexico's
wild mustangs.
MALE SPEAKER: As
I was growing up,
we were used to seeing
a lot of wild horses.
But a lot of the
horses that you see,
those are the
domestic horses that
have been dumped by private
owners that financially
couldn't take care of them.
NARRATOR: New episodes
every Tuesday.
Please subscribe.